نعم بحث وزير الدفاع الامريكي لودو اوستن
مع نظيره الاسرائيلي يقف غالنت اهميه تجنب
السياسات التي قد تقوض الامن والاستقرار
في الضفه الغربيه وقال ان تنتج هنا في
بيان ان اكد لنظيره الاسرائيلي خلال اتصال
على التزام الولايات المتحده الراسخ بامن
اسرائيل
وتفوقها العسكري النوعي
ايضا تهديدات الانشطه الايرانيه المزعزي
على الاستقرار وفرصه تعزيز التعاون
العسكري بين واشنطن وتل ابيب فضلا عن دمج
اسرائيل في المنطقه
المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه نات فايس
وصف الامر بغير الشرعي اي قرار لبناء اي
مستوطنه او اي تشريع للبؤره الاستيطانيه
عفوا في عمق الضفه الغربيه او على الاراضي
التي يملكها الفلسطينيات
في الضفه الغربيه
او السماحي باي نوع من البناء في عمق
الضفه الغربيه والاحياء الفلسطينيه او على
الاراضي التي يملكها الفلسطينيون